the common perception tends to be that
equality like kindness or
loving-kindness or compassion is a sort
of weakness that it makes you sort of
silly or very complacent that you're
only gonna say yes they're only gonna
say yes you can move in you can take
over my apartment I'll give you all my
money just keep doing what you're doing
it's fine well maybe it's not fine at
all and so we really need to look at
that as well why do we have such a sense
of love or loving kindness that it's
almost degraded into this kind of
foolish reaction as compared to the
force that it genuinely is we really can
redefine strength and not see compassion
for example as giving in and just being
too soft and and being a doormat letting
someone walk over you but understanding
we can have a genuine compassion for
someone and also protect ourselves and
want to take care of ourselves or
protect others and have a strong
boundary and say no and even be fear so
kind of intense and how we relate to
somebody but we don't have to have that
kind of obsession you know how we can go
through someone's list of faults like
all day long and then we go through it
again and it's the same list it's not
like we learn new faults but we're so
caught up it's like we've given so much
of our own life energy over to someone
else that we want to recapture it we
want to be free and so one of the ways
of doing that is really having a genuine
compassion for the pain that this this
person is also in without having it lead
to that kind of weakness so I've often
thought that in this society at this
time that we tend to see kindness as a
sort of secondary virtue it's like if
you can't be brilliant and you can't be
courageous and you can't be wonderful
like okay because it's nice they're not
great but it's good but it is great it
actually is great to really feel into
the pain of someone and to wish them
well not wish them to be triumphant and
what they're doing but wishing that they
could be free of that pain we
is the source of their negative behavior